orioles super fan mo gaba sadly passed
away yesterday afternoon mo represents
all of birdland as the tenth man
george
gets ready to face the yankee lineup dj
lemay who's in swinging a fly ball a
right looking towards the corner this
one's defense but stays fair and this
one is gone dj la mayhew takes walter
howskey out
in right field le mayhew behind the
baseball driving it the other way what a
way to start the day there's aaron judge
in right side
there's a ground ball looks like you've
got to put into the catcher
and it's going to be catchers in
appearance so judge will reach
now here comes stanton
half swing and i think this is another
catcher's interference i think you're
right
second one against pedro severino it's
the first that loads the bases with one
half mike ford steps in
[Applause]
driven deep to right field
but right there is santander the scoring
from third tagging is aaron judge so an
rbi for fourth and it's two nothing
yankees he's with a two-nothing lead
bottom of the first pays down at first
base
that's hit will deep right field judge
heading back he won't get it austin
hayes motoring around third he gets the
green light and he'll score so jose
iglesias continues to hit the ball hard
and the orioles got the lead to 2-1
aaron judge starts off the inning one
and two
high-fly ball deep left going back
stewart on the track at the wall see ya
a home run for judge and the yankees
lead three to one ball up in the strike
zone the one that you're supposed to
swing on underneath he got just enough
of it aaron hicks
and hicks drives one to right field
fairball it is gone it is gone a two-run
home run for hicks and the home runs
same thing as 2019 three in the game the
yankees lead five to one this ball was
just belted a line bottom of the fifth
he acts up five to one dwight smith jr
against garrett cole 2-2 swinging a miss
and smith down on strikes really good
knuckle curve he takes a little bit off
of this one because he's way out in
front severino the catcher here's the
02. a swing and a miss oh severino had
no chance over matched is the word
another punch out for garrett cole two
up two down two strikeouts here at the
bottom of the fifth and the two outs
chance for dj le mayhew to salvage the
inning
that's a base hit the left center field
off the bat of la mayu
rounding third and heading home is ford
he'll score easily another ribby for
lemayo and the yankees lead six to one
this is what he does he'll hit the ball
away hard stuff away this breaking ball
he's out front a little bit he'll pull
that into a hole just off the end of the
bat this is why he is so good with men
in scoring position is because he
continues to be the same hitter here's
aaron jones
flying drive that is a basic to left
center field scoring easily is urshela
the mayhew goes to third judge goes to
second and he is gunned down trying to
stretch on
this one back deep will it get over the
wall it does and gone so dwight smith
with a two-run homer that leg kick and
he timed it up perfectly and i mean
melted this one austin hayes against the
lefty o2 pitch
up high fly ball right field judge over
fair territory makes the catch to end
the inning one out back up top to dj
lemay who's had a heck of a night
ground ball
up the middle of base hit what a night
for lemayo
he is four for five
globe rezo for ford
that one gets away
from severino as both the runners move
up the maybe the third and judge the
seventh he got crossed up because he
turned his he turned his glove the other
way you're stanton with the bases loaded
and one out
now when it's ripped to left field it is
a base hit lemay scores easily judge
will stop at third it's an rbi single
for stanton and it's 8-3 yanks he stays
on top of the ball so well and he's so
short that if he is filled a little bit
that pan will come off the back bottom
of the ninth inning in the end he's
bringing brooks crisky this is his major
league debut two and two
strike three and krisky gets his first
big league strikeout two away the
orioles are down to their final one
really tight slider probably too close
to take last chance for the o's is dj
stewart
and the 3-2
wing and a miss and that'll do it
as chrisky strikes out two in his major
league debut he's going to save that
baseball and the yankees win by a score
of 9-3